What message would you
guys like the gatekeepers
of Hollywood, studio heads,
producers, the writers,
the casting directors,
what message would you
like them to know?
I think I would love to let
them know that they shouldn't
get too overwhelmed right now.
I think we're in a really
big process of change.
And there are a
lot of people who
are wanting to share their
stories and their experiences.
And I think that there are so
many more people we should be
welcoming into this industry.
I would love for them
to be more open-minded
about closed captioning,
not only for people
who speak English,
but for those who
are deaf and hard
of hearing, as well
as those who speak other
languages in other countries.
I know that here we primarily
look at everything with a lens
that we're Americans,
but I think
that we have so
much rich knowledge,
and there's media out
there that we could share.
I think we need to be
doing more listening.
We need to be more
compassionate.
And that's what I would
like them to know.
I am going to say about the
writers, writer and directors,
I would say they
are so very awesome,
awesome and great and plus,
the producers have been working
very hard and are focused
and doing all the camera,
then go from --
I would say both ways
and do that and do this.
So they have been doing a
pretty, pretty good job.
That's great.
I would say to writers, put in
characters with disabilities.
Directors, talk to consultants
to help you with this stuff.
And then when casting,
cast disabled people.
It used to be that
non-disabled people loved
to play disabled people.
But now, let disabled
people play themselves.
So that's what I would
love Hollywood to do.